[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم جهود اغاثه منكوبي
السيول تتواصل في ليبيا بعد اكثر من اسبوع
على الفيضانات الكارثيه التي خلفت الاف
القتلى والمفقودين وزير البيئه في حكومه
الوحده ناشد عبر الجزيره تقديم دعم عاجل
بينما اكد وزير الصحه بالحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان للجزيره وجود نقص في التجهيزات
الطبيه في حين حذرت الامم المتحده من نفاد
الوقت امام جهود الاغاثه
اما في تداعيات زلزال المغرب المدمر
تتواصل عمليات البحث عن ناجينه وانتشار
جثث الضحايا بعد مضي اكثر من اسبوع على
وقوع الزلزال بالتزامن مع بدء تفعيل الخطط
الحكوميه لدعم وايواء المتضررين واعلن
السلطات فتح جميع الطرق الرئيسيه المتضرره
في اقليم تارودانت وقد كانت وزاره
الداخليه قد افادت بارتفاع عدد قتل
الزلزال الى 2946
تحت حمايه مشدده من قوات الاحتلال مئات
المستوطنين والمتطرفين اليهود يقتحمون
باحات المسجد الاقصى ويقومون باداء طقوس
تلمديه بينما اعتادت الشرطه الاسرائيليه
بالضرب على المرابطين في باب السلسله وفي
ردود الفعل ادانت وزاره الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه الاقتحام في حين اكدت حركه
حماس ان الفلسطينيين جميعهم موحدون في
الدفاع عن الاقصى
على متن قطاره المصفح الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي يغادر روسيا بعد زياره استمرت
خمسه ايام التقى فيها الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وتلقى كيم جونغ اون قبل
مغادرته عده هدايا شملت خمسه مسيرات
انتحاريه واخرى للاستطلاع وستره واقيه من
الرصاص كهديه من حاكم منطقه بريمورسكي في
شرق روسيا الى اللقاء